I am 22 years old and I just graduated
undergrad and got married the next day
my wife and I don't have any debt but um
two weeks after our wedding my mother
passed away oh no and um she died at 61
so she left us um her Ira which has
about 300,000 in it and then the main
reason I'm calling is because um the
house that she left has $60,000 left on
it and and I'm just wondering should I
what I'm planning to do is rent it out
and have my renters pay the mortgage
number one uh renting a property as a
landlord is not passive
income that's humorous uh that's crap
from Tik Tock okay uh because there's
nothing passive about dealing with
renters I've got a bunch of them uh I
have been I am planning to hire a a
property doesn't matter it's not passive